hi I'm Kristen Bell and I'm excited to
be narrating the new IMAX documentary
pandas come join me at your local IMAX
theatre and follow the story of these
adorable pandas as we return them to
their home in the wild watch this
special behind-the-scenes piece now
[Music]
so our story takes place mostly in
Sichuan province in southwestern China
this film is about a little cub named
Chen Chen who was born in captivity and
has chosen to be the first panda to go
through this very groundbreaking panda
reintroduction program pandas are
endangered their habitats have been
encroached upon and some destroyed and
it's a story of releasing one panda into
the wild in hopes of bolstering the
panda population and saving the species
our cast in this film besides pandas is
made up of really interesting people
then killing you developed this
technique to rehabilitate orphan black
bear cubs and reintroduce them into the
wild that inspired a Chinese scientist
to mimic that with pandas Rong is a
really incredible scientist who develop
innovative techniques for captive
breeding
she's largely responsible for building
this robust captive panda population
just as Ben Killam has made it possible
for us to understand black bears his
protege Jake Owens has been able to
establish a relationship with tension
I first met Jen when she was about six
months old and she was extremely
affectionate she would come up to me
climb on to me and then fall asleep
Jake's relationship with Chen Chen is
just tremendous they chose Chen Chen for
group and a reintroduction program
because he saw something in tension a
curiosity and a courage and a spark the
key to this is developing a relationship
between the researchers and the Panda
because the humans and the pandas have
to work really closely together for a
couple years my hopes for tensions
futures she finds a home range
she starts reproducing and having babies
and her cubs that we want to go on and
be completely free living pandas in the
wild this is a story about connections
between people between cultures even
between animals kristin is really the
perfect person to narrate this film and
we're just so happy she's doing it
Kristen has such an incredible empathy
for animals
and really you know cares about them the
only way you can really bring an
audience into this world is with the
IMAX experience IMAX is so immersive it
really transports you into the actual
environment it feels like you're there
right beside the pandas it's a really
unique experience
[Music]
[Music]